[Music]
every morning starts the same
coffee and crossword
[Music]
religious conflicts
[Music]
it all seems so
apocalyptic
none of this is new however
we've been predicting the end of the
world for thousands of years
from nostradamus all the way back to the
book of revelation
something about the drama of
annihilation seems to grip us
is it just human nature to
worry and wonder about the end of days
or is it really coming
i'm setting off on a journey
to find out why so many religions
predict an apocalypse
this beast has a human name its number
is
666.
to discover the roots of judgment day
the sons of light shall battle the sons
of darkness
our ancient prophecies
there's no peace between us and our
neighbors
reverberate today
if these guys ever came to power it
would be hell on earth
and to ask whether the end is really
what we imagine
or if it's all just in our minds
[Music]
my first destination is jerusalem
the spiritual set of the jews
christians
and muslims
all three of those faiths predict
jerusalem will play a role
in the end of the world
it has long been a flash point for
religious tension
i've come here to meet yurum hasani
an expert in the politics and theology
of judaism
i want to know why the end of days is so
closely tied to this city
you're looking at the absolute epicenter
of the monotheistic world right over
there that's the dome of the rock which
according to islamic tradition muhammad
ascended to heaven from right that spot
and over there
the mount of olives and gethsemane below
where jesus and his disciples used to
meet and of course down here is the the
western wall plaza the holiest shrine
prayer location for
all of the jewish people in judaism
this whole area is called the temple
mount this is the temple mount the
temple was
a building seven stories high
stood on top of this
temple mount on top of that flat area
where those trees are
in 20 bc
king herod the great built a temple
where jews could worship their god
it was designed to last forever herod
says we're going to create the most
spectacular physical structure in the
entire middle east maybe the entire
world
you can see these gigantic stones at the
bottom those are called herodian stones
the jewish temple to the one god
stood on top of that mount before there
was islam or christianity
but in the year 70 a.d the romans sacked
jerusalem and demolished the temple
in the centuries since jews have come to
pray at its remains the western or
wailing wall
it was almost 1900 years before the site
returned to direct jewish control in
1967
we are about 70 years into
the new israel
bias the temple have been rebuilt
two reasons
one is because the jews aren't ready
and the other is because the muslims
aren't ready
the state of israel militarily
politically controls this whole area but
the state of israel gave
the temple mount area on the top to the
muslims
while the top of the mount is off limits
to jewish religious rights
there are sacred spaces underground
chris joram says will help me understand
the jewish vision for end times
this is it
we've come to the closest that a human
being can come to the holy of holies the
most sacred spot in the world that's the
room in the temple that one human being
would enter once a year the high priest
on yom kippur on the holiest day of the
year and he would say
god's name
orthodox jews believe that without this
temple
their religious rights are incomplete
so they await the day when their temple
is rebuilt
is there a messiah in judaism and
judaism jews invented the messiah
but it's not the same messiah that most
people think about okay because when
christians think of the messiah they
think of someone who's divine yeah they
think of you know the end of days what
we have for the messiah is a man a king
of this earth who's going to bring peace
among the nations
in this world
and he will not be divine it will not be
divine
and
euron tells me this mortal messiah has a
very specific to-do list
according to jewish tradition he has
three things he's supposed to do number
one he's going to reconstitute the
jewish kingdom for the jewish state
number two he's going to bring peace
with the neighbors and number three he's
going to rebuild that until the temple
here we are this is
2015 what are you going to do now what
is contemporary jewish position on the
temple the jews think of the world in
terms of
this
dream that once existed in the world
that was taken away
they just want to bring back into the
world that is the reconstruction of the
temple the reconstruction of the temple
as the the crowning symbol
of this era of justice and peace that
we're supposed to be
assisting to bring back into the world
judaism is just one of many religions
that envisions to come into world peace
one day
but looking at this place
where so many religions intersect
it's hard to imagine peace coming
rebuilding the temple now would almost
certainly not herald an age of peace
it would obliterate some of the holiest
sites in islam
in fact
it might even trigger an apocalyptic
battle
but the idea of a violent end of the
world is not new
two thousand years ago not all jews
anticipated a coming age of peace
one jewish sect fervently anticipated a
bloody apocalypse
archaeologist jody magnus has taken me
to the shores of the dead sea
where their ancient prophecies
were miraculously preserved
welcome to qumran
right right this is where the scrolls
were found right that's right the dead
sea scrolls were found in 11 caves in
the cliffs surrounding qumran
how did they get up there
well they were deposited in the caves by
the people who lived at qumran who were
members of a jewish sect called the
essenes
so
why why come here
they came out here to the desert because
they wanted to live in isolation apart
from everyone else
jody tells me that the essenes settled
here at qumran around 100 bc
they believed an epic battle was coming
one that would bring on the end of the
world
thanks to the incredibly dry climate
here
their apocalyptic writings have been
preserved for more than 2 000 years
looking over the edge of the cliff here
look at what we see below us
holy cow
this cave is very important
approximately 700 different scrolls were
found in this cave
including fragments of the war squad
the war scrolls what now what is that
that's this role that describes a
40-year long apocalyptic war and one of
the famous lines from the scroll says
there shall be a war of terrible carnage
the sons of light shall battle the sons
of darkness
and it shall end in eternal redemption
this war that they're talking about is
that like a call to revolution
or
is it more like a mythological
expectation when you read the war scroll
one of the interesting things is that it
interweaves
real and then what seems to us to be
fantasy
the people who are leading them into
battle are priests who are dressed in
priestly outfits the fact that they talk
about angels fighting in their midst but
the soldiers are equipped in the way
that soldiers at that time were equipped
so you have a combination of what seems
to be very real um combined with things
that to us seem to be imaginary
like many doomsday cults the essenes
believed the end was imminent
and took precautions to be ready to meet
god at any moment
this is one of the ritual baths here at
qumran
they literally believed that god's
presence dwelled in their midst
according to biblical jewish law if you
enter the presence of the god of israel
you have to be in a state of ritual
purity
so all of these pools were filled by the
flash flood waters
but water was not replenished over the
course of the year so it got pretty
gross uh nevertheless it was still
considered pure for the purposes of
ritual immersion you could probably come
close to walking on it yeah you could
probably cut it with a knife at that
point
so
they were
all here preparing themselves for the
apocalypse that's right what happened
well the apocalypse sort of did arrive
but not the kind of apocalypse that they
anticipated
in 68 a.d their battle with the sons of
darkness took place
it was the romans
as part of their campaign to crush a
jewish revolt against their rule
they wiped homerun and the essenes
off the map
so the romans uh arm is just was
sweeping past here and all these people
are in the way
just get rid of them that's exactly
right the romans were basically subduing
the entire area
but the idea of an apocalyptic battle
with the forces of darkness did not die
with the essenes
it crept into another faith
one that was just being born
all roads lead to rome
that's where i want to uncover how the
christian idea of the end of days began
its most famous book of prophecy
revelation written around 100 a.d
foretells an impending battle with the
antichrist
let anyone with understanding calculate
the number of the beast
or it is the number of a person
its number
is six 666.
i want to know if i can calculate the
number of the beast
[Music]
i've come to the biblioteca casa natenzi
near the vatican to meet an expert in
early christianity
kim haines eisen
she tells me
she has compelling evidence that reveals
the identity of the beast
[Music]
good morning
so
what exactly do we have here
well i've been looking at some fragments
of the book of revelation
the book of revelation that's right the
book of the end of days the end of days
the apocalypse it's a prophetic book
it's got loads of symbolism
but it's also very much a political book
and making a political claim
about
the cause of evil
the cause of evil or who's responsible
for evil
so tell me about this coding because as
i understand it the antichrist was given
a code so they would never call his name
they would just say it by
code well there has been a lot of debate
about what this number in particular 666
who it refers to
there has also been a
strong argument made for 666 referring
to nero
nero was emperor of rome from 54 to 68
a.d
around the time when the first
christians began to arrive in rome
so
how do you make six six
six
translate to nero when you apply
numerical values to the name kaiser
neuron
and you add up those numbers you come to
666.
in ancient greek
and hebrew
every letter had a corresponding number
if you add up the letters of the name
for emperor nero written in hebrew
kaiserniron
the total comes to six six six
but nero is just one of many names that
can add up to 666.
kim believes a later copy of the book of
revelation found in an archaeological
dig in egypt
confirms the beast is nero one of the
interesting things about these fragments
is that we've got
two different numbers
what are those letters
a key is a 600 xc 60 sigma a6
666
this one over here we have a yoda sigma
616 with a line over the top
why is it you might think that this
number
destroys the possibility that it could
be
nero yes what's striking about this
is that it may help to confirm
the identity of nero
because this would be the number that we
would get if we spelled nero according
to the latin spelling
nero kaiser
without the n the letter n represented
50
the number 50.
so 666 minus 50
616. so we've just just subtract and
we're going to come up with six one six
and we have the same guy that's right
i'm so clever
[Music]
but why might early christians have
called nero the antichrist
kim brings me to the very heart of the
vatican saint peter's square to show me
the answer
so we know that the code 666 refers to
the emperor nero
why
emperor nero was despised for many
things
including persecuting christians
now in the square here you can see an
obelisk that he arranged to
stand at the turning point in his circus
circus maximus uh the circus
neuroneus erroneous yeah the circus
stood here
and was a place for chariot races games
but he also used it then for persecuting
christians
so in 64
there was a major fire in rome and much
of the city was destroyed
nero wound up blaming christians and he
executed them
in great numbers as far as we can tell
right here in this circus
tradition says nero even executed the
man many considered to be the founder of
the church in rome
peter
the story about peter was that he was
crucified upside down some of them were
lit on fire
burning
to light the place it explains why they
despised him so much
so now we have the basilica of saint
peter standing here commemorating his
death
so the irony
this is
where peter founded the church yeah it's
pretty dramatic
the crucifix on which peter died could
have been just yards from where i stand
now
obviously the christians hated nero
he was the antichrist
even after his suicide they appeared
that he had the power to come back and
rule
which was why i was safer to refer to
him in a secret code
but the christians
living under the conditions that they
were living
judgment day couldn't come too soon
the christian idea of apocalypse took
hold under the oppression of rome
this evil empire had destroyed jerusalem
and persecuted the early followers of
jesus
but the idea has since spread to a
different faith
it targets a different evil emblem
threatens to engulf us all in the
apocalypse
[Music]
i'm traveling the world to find out why
billions of people believe in the end of
days
my journey has brought me to islam
islam is an arabic word that means
surrender
submission to god's will
same god the jews and christians worship
meeting muslims face to face i've
learned that islam aims for people to
live in peace
but watching the news today
you'd be forgiven for not knowing that
a tiny percentage of muslims are waging
war against the west
isis and other religious extremist
groups believe the apocalypse has
already begun
to understand why
i've come to new york
to meet a man who was once a high-level
recruiter for an apocalyptic islamist
group
was radicalized as a teenager in the uk
please tell me about
that radicalization i think it's
important just to distinguish between
islamism and islam a religion what i
mean by islamism is the desire to impose
any version of islam over society
that ideology was sold to me as if it
was the religion of islam and that's
when i adopted i grew up facing a very
very severe form of violent racism
domestically within the uk i'm talking
hammer attacks machete attacks by
neo-nazi skinheads bugs
on many occasions i had to to watch as
my friends were stabbed before my eyes
as a 15 year old i began seeing myself
as separate from the rest of society and
an islamist recruiter found me in that
state as a young angry teenager and it
was very easy for that recruiter i
joined a group called hezbollah and
that's the uh the group i spent 13 years
on the leadership on
[Music]
is that the precaution true al-qaeda yes
it's the first islamist organization
that was responsible for popularizing
the notion of resurrecting a modern day
theocratic caliphate as we now see that
isis has laid claim to but my former
group they were the first ones to
popularize that term
i've ended up in egypt where i continue
to recruit people to this cause i was
eventually arrested on the 1st of march
2002
i was taken to the headquarters of the
state security in cairo down underground
in their torture dungeons
i was blindfolded
and that's where the worst ordeal began
they began electrocuting everyone
you served
four years fourth person
and then you came out
not so radical
i am still a muslim but i'm now liberal
now when i was in prison
and i was living with the the who's who
of the of the jihadist terrorist
movements and islamist movements we have
a leader of the muslim brotherhood i saw
and i thought my god if these guys ever
came to power and declared a caliphate
it would be hell on earth
of course when isis eventually did
declare the caliphate that utopian dream
that we all used to share
has become that dystopic nightmare that
we see now
so let's talk a little bit about isis
and the apocalyptic prophecies of
muhammad and how they are using that for
their purposes yeah so there are a lot
of prophecies that most muslims share
in common with each other the difference
is what isis has done
is it's manipulated those prophecies to
serve its own political and ideological
end
so there's an example of this uh end of
times battle that isis believes is going
to take place in a small village called
in syria
now this village has absolutely no
strategic value militarily whatsoever
has hardly any economic strategic value
either but isis has never the less
committed resources to conquering this
small village called david they believe
that the international community in the
coalition
must somehow be driven to come and meet
them in davich and engage in a final
battle
would that be part of the apocalypse
that america would fall
yeah
now this prophecy of the prophet
muhammad that says that constantinople
will fall first and then rome will fall
so isis has uh interpreted this piece of
scripture that because constantinople
has already fallen to muslims that the
next big battle will be against the west
and the west will eventually fall the
idea would be that actually in fact that
america today represents rome
you know a continuation of western
civilization as represented by the roman
empire
why do you think
the idea
of the
apocalypse is so appealing particularly
to so many young people when you feel
powerless when you feel
that you don't actually control your own
destiny when you feel that you have
absolutely no voice
then it's incredibly tempting though
wrong to feel like you're becoming an
agent of destiny to suddenly feel like
you do have a voice that you are shaping
history
magent now runs the quillian foundation
whose goal is to prevent isis and groups
like them from recruiting people in the
west
he produces counter propaganda videos
like this and i hope
they're treating you like the hero
so we've taken real examples of people
who've become disillusioned and we put
them to actors voices and actually put
out some of those stories
thank you thank you
both informative
and i'm glad you're here thank you
it's a pleasure
it's probably natural that the
apocalypse is appealing to the
disenfranchised
they have the most to gain
and the least to fear from overturning
the status quo
but it's more widespread than that
culturally
we
seem to have um morbid attraction to the
apocalypse
it's almost as if we draw some
comfort from it
at the university of illinois at chicago
psychology professor stuart shankman
is studying our subconscious belief in
the apocalypse he thinks it may be
hardwired into our brains
so the gist of what we're doing today is
we're looking at people's different
response to different kinds of threats
since this is a lab experiment that
relies on volunteers
the catastrophe is survivable
a certain noise combined with a mild
shock to the wrist
a skull cap of electrodes and sensors on
the subject's face
captured the raw data of fear her brain
activity and her stress levels
together
they measured the size of the starter
response
the first condition is called shock at
any time and during that you might
receive it when the countdown reaches
one you might receive it in the middle
of the countdowns you might receive it
in between your countdowns you might not
receive it at all
oh there's a big startle for the
unpredictable condition
when people are in the unpredictable
condition they don't know when this bad
thing is coming they're going to show a
greater activity in their brain and
pupil dilation their heart rate is going
to increase
now stuart changes to a different
condition
a predictable shock
it's called shock at one and you will
get a shock at the end of the countdown
your reaction to this painful but
foreseeable shock is different
surprisingly so
when people are in the unpredictable
condition their startle response is much
higher than when they're in the
predictable condition knowing when the
bad thing is going to come creates a
qualitatively different emotional
experience than
not knowing
so whatever we can do to try to make
something that's unpredictable
predictable that's going to give us a
little bit of solace
this mental mechanism could explain why
so many of us believe in an impending
apocalypse
but it may also explain the morbid
appeal of doomsday costs
i'll tell you about a kingdom level
beyond here and if you want to go there
then you have to follow me
this
is the end
of the age
but is it possible to predict the end
a few years back many people thought
they had
according to popular legend the ancient
maya thought the apocalypse would arrive
on a specific date
december 21st 2012
i want to know if this is really true
so i've traveled to their ancient
capital
tikal
in guatemala
i'm meeting stanley gunter who's a world
leading decoder of mayan inscriptions
so this is the temple of the masks
and on the other side
the temple of the giant jaguar
this would have been the very center of
the ancient city of tikal
and what about those
headstone looking things there those are
what we call stelite
stila c-neck
and they commemorate periods in the maya
calendar so we see that they would have
been dedicated to periods of time such
as every 20 years every 10 years and
especially every about 400 years the
ending of the great baktun cycles
the festival to mark the end of a baktun
cycle
would have culminated in the king
sacrificing the captive
does that go to say that the mayans felt
that 2012 would be the end of time the
apocalypse so we heard a few years ago
about 2012 when people said the end of
the 13th bachmann was going to be the
end of the world predicted by the maya
and there's a monument down here i think
we should take a look at that would help
explain that
this is stella ten
you can see we've got a king there's his
head big headdress full of feathers
his shoulders all of his jewelry
down to his feet if you look down below
we can actually see we have a captain we
can see his head we have his hands and
even down to his legs he's all tied up
for sacrifice
so now
what does this have to do with the
apocalypse well we have to go around the
other side here okay
we have a date that gives us a specific
point in time we have 11 years of 360
days
then we have three cottons that's about
20 years each so we've got another 60
and then here we have nine boktins
because this is a date of about 525 a.d
so if you remember we had 13 baktuns
ended in 2012.
but the really interesting thing is this
monument doesn't stop there
it goes on and tells us there were 19
of the higher unit the peak tune and
even higher we have 11 of the next unit
and so on each one of those units is 20
times larger than the previous so what
we see on this monument then is that 13
bacteriums wasn't the end of any
calendar
it was simply the end of one cycle
within a whole series of nested cycles
each one larger than the other
just as we mark the start of a new
millennium the maya marked december 21st
2012 as a major event on their calendar
the ending of another 400 year cycle
that would have been parades
music
and sacrifice
if the ancient maya was still here
they'd have had a huge party
no apocalypse no apocalypse just a
beginning another beginning and another
one and another one that would go on for
almost eternity
we've never found the end for the maya
we'll still have to keep searching
thinking about the way the maya saw time
makes me realize that the idea of an end
we have in christianity
judaism
and islam are not universal
for these religions the ultimate hope is
that
god will intervene
in the world of men
past judgment
and right the wrongs we see around us
but there are billions of believers out
there who don't see the world that way
at all
for them
time moves in cycles perhaps forever
i'm headed to india to understand what
the apocalypse could mean
in a world without him
[Music]
india is the birthplace of two great
religions
hinduism
and buddhism
[Music]
hindus believe an apocalypse comes every
few billion years
but every end leads to a new beginning
and the world starts again
buddhists don't imagine a violent end of
days
to them the word apocalypse does not
mean a revelation of god's judgment to
the world
it's a personal revelation of truth in
the mind
it's called
enlightenment
to find out what that means i've come to
sarnath india to meet one of the world's
most revered buddhist llamas
his holiness young kamata
[Music]
tibetan buddhists believe the kamapa is
the 17th reincarnation of a great
teacher who lived 900 years ago
[Music]
good morning
i think you should wear this i shouldn't
thank you
thank you yeah
can we walk yeah
in 1992
a holy commission headed for the new
karmapa and found ogen trinley dorje a
seven-year-old son of a nomadic family
in eastern tibet
are you kind of young for this station
yes
okay so what what is it like how do you
is it all right one way it's meaningful
one way is a little bit heavy
people have
lots of expectation
the expectation is heavy for a 30 year
old man
the karmapa must teach how to find
enlightenment
while still working to find it for
himself
this is the sort of decide that
the buddhas
give first teaching
this is the place then where he had his
first sermon after he reached
enlightenment yes yes
right
talk to me just a little bit your
wholeness about
enlightenment how does one even begin to
go about
trying to attain that
wow
big question isn't it yes huge challenge
yeah maybe i think
the first part is maybe you need to
recognize yourself like where are you
from come from why am i here yeah
so i i would like to
get some instruction yeah about
enlightenment
i will try i will try yeah okay okay
i'll try it
thank you
the comma patel's meditation is the key
to enlightenment
if the apocalypse is the revelation of
the true will of god
meditation aims to reveal the true will
of me
they have lots of different ways to
meditate
but the simple one is
to focus
focus your breathe
that's the one i know you relax your
mind
and don't
follow the path
don't anticipate future
just relax
at the moment
just focus your breathing
and
that's all
yeah
we should try
[Music]
it's a lot of work to move past all the
memories
thoughts
emotions
to just concentrate on being
to see what's left when all the noise is
gone
[Music]
is
[Music]
okay
beautiful good yes
thank you
can i ask you a philosophical question
philosophical
i will try it
it's about
[Music]
the
westerners
idea
yeah of
apocalypse
[Music]
the end of
time the end of being
is that such a thing in buddhism
when everything stops and every the
world comes to an end and mankind is
judged
we we believe every day it's
somewhere one universe it's it's uh like
in the ending one is beginning beginning
but it's not like he
just kind of judge how to say judge
things no judgment day no no judgement
day
this is a little bit different
so actually what you're saying i think
is that
there is no end only change yeah change
one thing ends another begins yeah maybe
it's there are not absolute sort of
ending
yeah
thank you thank you thank you
when you meet someone like his holiness
to come up
i guess the thing that stands out most
is
his humility
kamapa doesn't
give you the impression that
he thinks of himself as greater than you
higher than you
better in any way
than you
he's here
like the rest of us
on this quest
trying to
understand
why we are here
seeking to
unveil the truth
seeking enlightenment
but the truth isn't always revealed in a
moment of calm reflection
2005
hurricane katrina slammed into louisiana
a catastrophe
of historic proportions
some even thought the end was happening
here in new orleans
new
of orleans that was offensive to god and
i believe
that the hurricane katrina was in fact
punishment against the city
of new orleans
[Music]
katrina was a judgment from god
i'm in new orleans to meet katrina's
survivors
to learn how they dealt with the end
and how it changed them
so right now we're in flood country
yes sir this is where the water actually
yes this is actually the ninth ward
you were here during katrina is that
right yes i was i was in the apartment
building that was on the first floor oh
and
i got eight feet of water
and i lost everything i owned
did you have a feeling at some point
that this was like the end of it all
it did seem like the end to me
ernest was far from alone
new orleans residents charles and angela
marsalis came to their local church
a shelter in the time of the storm
we were in the carrollton avenue church
of christ this is you
spent a little time here during the
storm how did you wind up here we were
gonna
lodge here for the night
and then we were gonna go home the next
day
and
through the night we could uh
hear the winds rushing in
it's just really really loud i mean at
that time it was really scary um i just
began to kneel down and pray we could
actually you know see the water
rising and we thought it stopped it just
kept rising
the marsalis family was completely cut
off
more than a hundred billion gallons of
water had surged through broken levees
three days passed before the red cross
evacuated them to a maroon bridge
full of desperate survivors
it was like pitch black dark everything
in that water alligator snakes
everything
i mean they had sick people and they had
women in wheelchairs
we saw the guys
having drugs over there selling drugs
guns
yeah i felt that that was at work it was
really a dark time
it was really dark yeah now this these
are dire circumstances and dire
circumstances can bring out the best and
the worst in people yeah
how did you function through that
well i'm a minister and you got chairman
of the guard sitting here so i told my
wife
it's time for us to get busy we got to
do something
and so we just started singing and and
then the next day we know in the
darkness you could hear people saying
sing this song saying that song
and how i don't remember how long they
were saying all night
[Laughter]
we just knew that god would get us out
of there not even
not even katrina could shake that fate
i'm god no way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
charles and angela did get out in the
end
a year later they returned to new
orleans and rebuilt their lives
the experience of getting so close to
the end
and so close to god
drove them to start their own church
well how many of y'all here remember
katrina
y'all member of the stone
y'all remember
that some folk even said that that's god
punishment
on new orleans
and i had to tell them folk no
god allow it to happen
you know a lot of people had their eyes
on
new orleans but they saw something
good that could come out of something
bad had it not been for the stone we
wouldn't be here
and this building problem
we would we wouldn't have met some of
these people that you seen in here today
i believe everyone with that stone
you know john that's very buddhist
yeah yeah the buddhists say
every ending
is the beginning
it's god's will
god saw this before we saw this
we just can't allow ourselves
to be willing to let god use us and part
of that will
didn't watch new orleans of its sin
it didn't come as divine punishment
it caused suffering yes
but it also opened people's eyes
to cherish what they had left and to
work together
to build something better
i set out to understand what the
apocalypse means to people of many
different faiths
i had always thought of it as a all
destroying doomsday
but i've discovered that some people
yearn for the apocalypse
they want to be free of injustice
they want to escape
suffering they want a better world
apocalypse
it's a greek word
meaning lifting the veil
it's not about war it's about
enlightenment
it's not about death
it's a state of mind and heart that
helps us see the truth
not some far-off day of judgment
it's here
it's now
[Music]
[Music]
you